all of those blindfolded like touch my
body like what's in my mouth challenge
see I've never even done that before
every minute what that is really
blindfold a person and then you put
their hands somewhere on your body and
they have to guess what they're touching
got it yeah okay well I got to try that
sometime yeah but I want to do it with
you know like a football team or
something I've been a creeper since I
was a little kid are we recording right
now yeah okay all right that
introduction this is todrick everybody
you go by anything specific do you go by
todrick hall toddy
todrick Black Stallion sometimes I know
that you love all things Disney yes and
one of the big themes in most of Disney
movies is romance and love so I thought
that you would be a really great person
to help me give love advice to these
wonderful human beings that are watching
well I would love to I'm really good at
this but in fact can I just say I don't
know if this is too much you can ask
Colleen but when there was a moment in
time where Colleen and Josh like dated
and then worked together for years and I
was the person that brought them back
together whoa so you're welcome
everybody for the end that's going to
the Josh Ling tour you did that you and
I wasn't even invited to the wedding
well I'm doing I don't know my facebook
page and asked you guys for some
questions about love dating
relationships all of that and we're
gonna give you some advice right now
yeah how do I get someone to touch me
without wincing how do you get someone
to touch you without going huh yeah is
that a thing where you make sure that
there is consent there might be a bigger
issue here your approach there are some
people that have touched me that I've
been like yikes and it's not because of
their like fist my cat is out of control
she was scratching at the door so I was
so confused and trying to figure out
what wincing was what is the best way to
get over first date anxiety I think it's
okay to have some anxiety going into a
first date cuz it's really exciting if
someone's too cool calm collected I
think that they might be a psycho
murderer I think that anybody who's
looking for somebody who's like a
lifetime partner or at least somebody
that you can change your facebook status
for they're gonna be looking for
somebody who's a little bit nervous I
think if someone walks into the room
with way too much confidence that's like
a Gaston situation sorry for all of
these businesses no one wants to date
Gaston cuz he's too full of himself I
don't care if he's four dozen eggs every
morning to help him get large I don't
want to be involved with it I would much
rather date a beast
I might went sometimes when he touches
me but he still has a good heart
we're Beauty in the Beast right now who
is ooh no enough what do you do if he
doesn't touch your butt enough you never
had that problem if you date me I'm just
putting that out there who comes to mind
when you think like greatest but I have
a boyfriend so but my PC answer is Jesse
passed and my boyfriend hey Jesse I
would say that Channing Tatum there's a
few steamy yeah I haven't seen the movie
The Magic Mike not even just that one
but there's another movie where he's in
love with like what's the girl's name
from the notebook and uh Regina George
Shannon Rachel McAdams love her in that
movie it was worth the ticket because he
stood up and there was a really good
shot of those golden cakes and I wanted
to sign up for the hot cakes I didn't
mean to McDonald laughing Dana I watched
all of his movies like 9 million times
really yeah and they went double
platinum which movies can't even do I'm
producing Channing Tatum the musical huh
that would actually be a great musical
it would be sold out this video is
sponsored by Channing tomato how to
flirt with emojis because you're too shy
to talk do you have like go-to emojis
that you use all the time I do I do like
the kiss emoji because I love that I
love that they have they added like all
the different race emojis now so
sometimes I put them on there for no
reason just because I'm happy that
they're there all the Cosby kids like
together and there's one there's a black
guy with blond hair which never happened
which one is that let me show you guys
just in case any of you people out there
of color are thinking about going cisco
the blond-haired blond-haired guy but
they don't change the color of the hair
when you change the skin who's the
basketball player Dennis Rodman is Robin
they have emojis they can finally use I
don't really think that you should count
on emojis to flirt with anybody I think
that you should use your wit and your
sense of humor and really show people
what they are going to get as it tastes
like a trailer to what their life would
be if they were to elope or spend adult
time with you it's good that you have a
boyfriend already baby why does online
dating or an attempt to do so suck so
much for a gay virgin oh baby okay
that's I could yeah
man are already a mess it just in
general and girls have to be like okay
stop I have to maintain my like my
wholesomeness my integrity thank you for
being my interpreter and when you have
just a bunch of guys together they're
crazy I like really really applaud you
for even still being a gay virgin and I
think that you should stick to your
morals and ethics no matter what because
this community can be very scary and
very dangerous but there will be
somebody out there who has the same
morals and ethics that you do who would
love to fall in love with someone just
like you and it's gonna be harder to
find but it will be so worth it in the
end that is this might be the most
helpful video I've ever had on my
channel okay here's the last one
someone just confess their feelings for
me in a drunken emotional mess and I
have absolutely no feelings back for the
person what do I do
well first of all you should just
double-check with them tomorrow if they
still have those feelings because you
might not even have a problem I thought
you were Ashley you're a man I think
honesty is like my new thing for 2016
because 100% of the time no matter who
you are you sometimes get nervous to
approach your problems head-on and 100
percent of the time it's better for you
and that person you shouldn't want to
surround yourself by people who would
love to accept your honest opinion as
long as you say it in a nice way that
would not offend them to tell them
you're a really nice person and I would
love to be Facebook friends with you but
I don't want to be in a relationship
with you and I hope you can understand
that and appreciate it and maybe in a
year from now we can go see Channing
and musical together Wow I'm gonna title
this video
grace watches todrick give amazing
advice I can't at all add to that
because that was wonderfully
all-encompassing and very very helpful
cue well this was amazing yeah thank you
todrick make sure if you guys haven't
already to go check out Patrick's
channel subscribe to him follow him
across all social media platforms how do
they find you on everything I'm at
todrick on Instagram and soon to be
Twitter it's either @toddyrockstar or at
todrick I'm the only todrick my mom gave
me a really creative name it shout out
to my mom there's black women they know
how to come up with some creative Shh
and we did a video on my channel
together so you guys should watch it yes
and todrick's got a bunch of amazing
videos with himself and with a lot of
other youtubers that I'm in love with
these do yourself a favor and go like
Mark off like 3 hours of time and just
sit with his channel it's really really
great it's proud of me
hi guys I don't know we has a better
butt than Channing Tatum Beyonce Beyonce
Beyonce's got a better everything than
everyone I feel like Instagram like
gifts for more time or something like
what I'm watching I should never be
happy to be so long